welcome everyone I'm Saad Omar and my
title for the next six weeks is the
director of the Yale Institute for
Global Health
um and I'm also a professor both in the
schools of medicine and public health uh
here at Yale as most of you would know
um I am delighted to welcome you to our
last conversation series event
for
this Academic Year as you know this is
uh the conversation series Global Health
conversation series is run by the Yale
Institute for Global Health but this
event is in collaboration with the Yale
School uh for a school of Public Health
specifically with the epidemiology
epidemiology of microbial diseases
seminar series as well the overall the
conversation series is all co-sponsored
by the MacMillan Center and their Walker
fund as we have learned through the
covid-19 pandemic that Health Trust
sends boundaries uh you know something
that emerges in China shows up in
Washington and then within a week and a
half in Connecticut
um and and and and in many parts of the
country and the world
we have also learned that by promoting
healthy behaviors
um investing in healthcare
infrastructure and specifically with the
focus on Equity
um helps everyone both domestically and
internationally especially if these
lessons are shared and the beauty of
this country is a cooperative federalism
kind of a infrastructure is that we have
at least 50 Labs unfortunately not all
those lab experiments go well but but
the idea is that we learn from each
other especially if things are
implemented in good faith uh with the
best possible interpretation of uh
evidence but also evaluated and shared
so so that's the beauty of uh treating
the local health
as a part of a global whole uh that that
that we all benefit from
so in today's event we will discuss
these important issues and how Global
health is essentially
um sort of uh derives a lot of its
strength from for what happens locally
and for our discussion it is my immense
pleasure to to welcome two distinguished
experts and leaders joining us today so
the first one is Dr Manisha jatani she's
one of our own she's on public service
leave from
the school of medicine and and where
she's a professor of medicine she's her
day job these days is the commissioner
of the Connecticut Department of Public
Health a department which was actually
uh owes a lot of its existence and
founding to Dr Winslow who after whom
this Auditorium is named and so so this
institution has a long uh history of
contributing to the state's Public
Health infrastructure
um and she's the first India an American
to serve as a commissioner in the state
of Connecticut so again is is a leader
in from that aspect as well as we emerge
from the pandemic she obviously helped
lead the coveted response but but she
continues to focus and and that comes
into relief a little bit more uh efforts
to deal with
the other public health issues including
the tragic opioid crisis LED abatement
gun violence and especially
evidence-based approaches to addressing
it Mental Health
climate and health so that's an
existential threat we have that
transcends boundaries has Global and
local implications
maternal health and and drinking water
infrastructure improvements are some of
the other areas that she's focusing on
she's committed to Growing the public
health Workforce and which you all are
part of the public health emerging
Public Health Workforce
and uh and someone told me they're 40
percent vacancies are open in the
department of uh of Public Health is
that is that a little bit less than that
yeah
so exactly that's the point and
especially those of you who are sort of
you know formatting your CVS for May and
the ones who are graduating one of the
best things to do right after an mph
program is to work for a good well-run
State Health Department especially if
you don't have to break your lease uh
and so you know that's a that's a pitch
of staying engaged Etc and including
those who want to have a subsequent
research career as well and research or
a career in medicine so so this is uh so
not just those who wants to you know
work in a health department for for the
long term as well
my other guest is uh Dr Omer Shah he's
the Secretary of Health for the state of
Washington and he made that trip from
Texas so his uh training was at
Vanderbilt and a few other places and
then was the uh the health commissioner
for Harris County around Houston and led
the response both in emergencies and
Non-Emergency sort of Health Care
functions for that important populous
and diverse County in the U.S and
um was there when you know around
Katrina and and some other major
disasters around Ebola and zika and sort
of all sorts of things that came
his way it was almost like a Sandbox
video game where you know things were
you know thrown in his Direction and and
he you know came out of that stronger
and with several lessons that he took
with him to the state of Washington but
beyond as well he's very active in the
National academies of medicine so over
his career he has been a clinician and
innovator an educator and a leader in
health he has been particularly
um a champion of underserved communities
but with a focus of substantive action
not just sort of talking about it which
is important but but taking action
um and and he's his career has always
been at the intersection of health and
Healthcare while charting a fresh course
in health by centering Cornerstone
values of equity Innovation and
engagement so we are honored to have you
both here and I'll start us off with a
few questions uh for for the two of you
and then we'll open it up uh to the
audience so the first question is
actually both of you
um
and both of you are you know
to to use a military term War tested
combat tested Generals in in public
health
what is the immediate course of action
to be taken locally when a global Health
event occurs so maybe Dr Shah I can
start with you and then with Dr chittani
well first of all thank you Dr Omar for
for having us as part of this convening
and thank you uh interim Dean Pettigrew
and and the entire School of Public
Health and just really appreciative of
the opportunity to be here so
um you know I think this is really the
the defining question
um as we are coming out of a pandemic we
see the question for the future about
when something happens globally
how do we act locally and I think this
really underscores the intersection of
global and domestic Health that we no
longer can be thinking about watching
something on the news cycle and
recognizing that it's over there
because there is no over there over
there is here and very quickly something
that can happen in Hartford or New Haven
can spread all the way across the globe
and flip it around the bi-directionality
of the fact that it can happen elsewhere
and now we're dealing with it here I
always saw with covid-19 initially when
and and obviously you know as Dr Marsh
said I was in Houston I was in Texas but
the state of Washington had the first
case as you know in the continental
United States of Coba 19 we had the
first case we had the first
unfortunately first outbreak and we also
had the first death
these are
Milestones they were unfortunate and sad
Milestones but they were also important
for the rest of the nation because what
was happening in Washington people like
us whether it was Connecticut or in
Texas were watching it play out and what
was happening in one part of the nation
or one part of the globe as we were
learning what was happening in obviously
in China but we were also seeing it
spreading through Iran and spreading
through Europe and spreading all the way
across to Other Nation States were
important lessons for all of us and so
I'm very used to in Houston hurricane
lines you all the spaghetti lines you
see you know there's a storm that's
about to hit you see all these lines and
I remember very early in the pandemic
thinking about where is the actual
spaghetti line for cover 19. the first
thing that all of us in public health
were trying to do was to figure out
where do we get where are we going to
have our first case in our local
jurisdiction and that was uh it was it
was really a disease detective case of
trying to find that first case and
ultimately
you had the spaghetti lines of
hurricanes and storms that were pointing
to where was going to happen across the
country and it just happened to be just
north of Seattle so I think the key
question the the real response is that
we cannot sit and rest on our Laurels
when something is happening elsewhere
because ultimately it will impact us
locally
thank you for the introduction so great
to be here with you Amer and all
the Yale community that I've been a part
of for a long time
um you know one I want to make one other
plug for the students which is there is
also a Connecticut Department of Public
Health Fellowship that people can apply
for for your summer experiences I see a
few people who maybe know what I'm
talking about but again this is what
gives you experiential learning you get
paid to to then be able to enter the
public health Workforce so to the point
in question about
what is global and now local
I want to just highlight even more when
we say local in the state of Connecticut
we think of the state as local if you're
first thinking about that but in the
state of Connecticut we have 61
Health departments and districts
the City of New Haven has a health
department we as a state need to work
with our local partners because that's
who's actually on the ground in the
community dealing with the Health crisis
as it's emerging and so we really have
to take local to the really local level
and it's really on us as the State
Health Department to be able to work
well it's been one of my priorities to
be able to work well with local Health
to be able to execute on these Concepts
and what I would say is that
as we've heard what is global global is
local
as an ID physician
we were sitting here at Yale New Haven
Hospital waiting to see where that first
case was going to emerge in the state of
Connecticut as we saw things coming and
then to New York and moving up that I-95
Corridor and where it was going to
happen so I saw it from the perspective
of a practitioner and director of the
yaleid fellowship program and you know
now our am at the state level and the
number one thing that I can say is
preparedness it's those preparedness
plans it's going through the exercise
and recognizing that any threat can
emerge at any time and you need to be
prepared for whatever that might be you
have to have plans in place they may
need to adapt and change depending on
the circumstances but without a plan it
is very hard to execute on that and
we've learned so much from the pandemic
which we have
put into place in terms of our plans and
preparedness as a state but without that
you're already behind the eight ball
when something emerges
so
um both of you lead sort of the health
efforts
in diverse States
Connecticut is a little bit more compact
Washington has both just not just
diversity in terms of its population but
also
World Views and geography so from you
know Spokane Etc in the East to Ferry
County which is it was a tea party
before there was a tea party to Vashon
Washington which is the peak of crunchy
granola former hippie current formerly
hippie currently Rich crowd and great
place to visit by the way yeah wonderful
post the whole state is wonderful and
Yakima County which is partially
populated but but you know reasonably
Pro Public Health
um so so with that diversity how do you
engage
the community
because it's not one Community how do
you work with Community leaders is there
a model to do that especially when you
can't be the health commissioner for
just the conservatives or just the
Liberals while being in a Democratic
Society where you know appointees are
political
yeah so first of all I would be remiss
if I did not join my colleague here to
remind everybody that we have great
internship opportunities as well great
volunteer opportunities we're a great
place to work we're an incredible state
so please come to the state of
Washington I just want to let people
know in this room and Beyond you know
please come and and we are absolutely uh
willing to to recruit and and and we're
not Shameless in the process I just
wanted to make that quick plug
um what I would say a couple of things
so you know I I came from a deep uh
deeply different maybe that's the the
better way to to say it uh context right
the state of Texas uh is uh on the
political Spectrum more conservative
it's it's what we refer to in the
popular vernacular of a red red State
um then you go to Washington and you've
got a a blue state so you got red and
blue what I find and you know Dr emmer
you and I have talked about this is that
you get that diversity
everywhere I'm sure you get that right
here
five minutes from this campus
you may get it right here in this room
think about that we assume that
everybody has a certain political
perspective or persuasion that is so
inaccurate so when I came to Washington
my first comment at my um one of my
press briefings was to say I am the
State Health secretary not just for one
side of Washington which everybody knows
is the I-5 Corridor everybody thinks of
Seattle and just north and just south
where the majority of our population is
in the state of Washington but I am the
State Health secretary for the entire
state of Washington and then that played
out in the midst of our vaccination and
our coveted response efforts that no
matter and our tagline was no matter who
you are what you look like where you
live or what you believe in
you should have access to and fill in
the blanks and that is what health does
it levels and evens out when there are
elected officials and policy makers who
are having the partisan discussions we
must rise above that
no matter what we have to be connecting
across the aisle because our communities
are on both sides of that aisle and
shame on us in public health if we're
unwilling to do that and that's where
the diversity not just of the community
comes in but the diversity of us as
practitioners comes in as well
so you are right that there is
intellectual diversity in this room they
are indeed 15 shades of work uh here and
I'm just joking there is to I have found
true intellectual disc you know our
students here I'm very proud of the fact
that the discussions have been
substantive there have been multiple
ways of looking at the world
um Etc and so you're absolutely right in
that coming to the more operational
issues so when you're doing a response
but also more broadly so so the job of a
health commissioner or Secretary of
health is not just strategic not just
Visionary but also operational
so how do you maintain that logistical
resilience
both for the emergency response but also
the the other things people are going to
need a set of screenings
and referrals and all sorts of other
stuff so how do you operationally manage
that so maybe Dr jitani
so I came into the job as commissioner
in the middle of the pandemic and within
a few months of being in the job
Omicron took off
so I came into the job when we were
running fast
and had to figure out the job and figure
out how to do emergency response while
at the same time not completely dropping
the ball on all the other routine Public
Health types of things that we need to
do and we see the consequences quite
frankly in our society of the fact that
it was difficult to manage social
distancing and children being out of
school and we see that impacts of that
on Mental Health on gun violence on so
many other aspects maternal mortality
congenital syphilis rates in Connecticut
we had eight cases of congenital
syphilis in the last year when we had
years of none zero that is because of a
lack of access and accessing of maternal
Health Services for many women and
that's a travesty we know how to deal
with that that's just regular old Public
Health doing what it does what medical
care when it's running in its usual way
in our state really is so I think for me
we were sort of flying the plane and
building it as it was going you know so
for example self-test kits were just
coming out and we were trying to buy
them and respond to the Omicron wave as
it was all happening
and so you know now everybody's got more
kits than they know what to do with
um you know and but that was different
back then now we're trying to continue
to rebuild and maintain that
infrastructure on so many of the General
Public Health
basic principles that we need to have in
place and it's a different Tempo in some
ways but every day there's a new
emergency quite frankly that comes up
it's this different in scale there may
be a smaller group of people that are
affected by that given emergency it's
not maybe the entire State and I think
that I just want to make one comment
about even though we are a blue State
boy do we have diversity in this state
we have rural areas of this state we
have all the same disparate voices that
you see in a red State and we have the
same challenges even though we are
generally viewed as a pro-public health
type of state where people often think
people are of the same mindset that is
not the case and you do have to have an
open mind and recognize Health as a
human right and being able to provide
that to everybody and not just those who
are the same
mindset As You Are
so when you arrived from Texas to
Washington
um
in terms of you arrived when the vaccine
became available so right around the
time that same week same week my wife
was not happy with that decision and
um
and then sort of Washington has done
fairly well in terms of equitable
distribution of vaccines in terms of
objective metrics Etc obviously it took
some effort and all of that
what are some of the the approaches that
specific approaches that you applied to
make that happen
well that's uh you know it's a it's it's
a long uh it's a short question long
answer I'll try to keep it very brief
um there were a number of things that we
did and I did arrive the week of
vaccines in the state fortunately I
arrived in a department
um that was supported by a governor I
have to be very very clear Governor
Inslee uh was a champion for health and
continues to be many people know him in
environmental health and climate climate
change and the impact on climate on
health but that translated and
transferred over to his uh
um reading and and studying and and
commenting and being all in when it came
to covid-19 response and so yes the
first first uh case first outbreak first
death and yet you fast forward two years
later and um or two plus years later and
we uh still have the sixth slowest uh
per capita uh death rate in the in the
nation and that's quite amazing when you
think about all that so the specific
strategies uh Dr remember we're really
very much that it was all in for
Washington that we had to do everything
we could we did the work with our local
Health jurisdictions we have 29
officially recognized tribes so we
worked with our tribal leaders we worked
with our faith leaders we were in
communities we we actually for the first
time had a state asset called Caravan
where we deployed State
units that went into to communities that
communities 700 of them asked us to come
in and help with vaccinations we had
collaborators for Equity so we had
Community voice we also had a
public-private partnership so in the
midst and this is really hard for
government
government oftentimes stays on the
public sector side right so we had our
Starbucks right we had Amazon we had
Costco we had Microsoft we had Gates
Foundation we had Google I mean just
Alaska Air we had all of these these
folks who were saying what can we do to
help we brought them together so when
Starbucks said to us the governor asked
us there's a specific example we need uh
I want to make sure you're going to
stand up for Mass vaccination sites in
the next 48 hours
and we did it okay
but we stood them up and we reached out
to our private sector partner who were
part of our collaborative and Starbucks
said if we can get a latte in the hands
of consumers 35 percent more effectively
and efficiently we guarantee you we can
make your mass fact site faster and more
efficient and guess what they were right
but Shame On Us in public sector for
unwilling to take that offer that's the
kind of all in Washington approach that
we took to unturn overturn every stone
to be able to respond and that's how we
were successful
I think that that's a really good
example of that as long as Starbucks is
not putting down names of people on cups
or vaccines so I've been called making a
comment on that one exactly SOB or sad
Etc sometimes that reflects the state of
mind after I look at that but but other
than that no it's it's it's leveraging
um sort of it's the all truly all hands
on deck approach so both of you not only
Public Health leaders but but our
employers of uh folks that come out of
the public health education system a lot
of them from the schools of Public
Health and Medicine
Etc and nursing
what do you think if you had
um the choice of redesigning the skill
set
that people come out with from these
programs that is relevant to not just a
health department for Applied Public
Health what would be your advice if you
were given that opportunity so maybe we
can start with Dr jatanian and if you
might want to add something there and
that's something for everyone both
faculty and others that we need to be
connected we need to be responsive uh to
the needs of Health departments and the
the broader local and state public
health
so I think there's different types of
roles in local Health departments at the
state level so for example
epidemiologists that deal with data you
maybe get very good training at learning
how to analyze data how to gather data
and be able to present it I think some
of the other skills that are really
useful in health departments relate to
project management being able to provide
deliverables be able to present
data more publicly learning how to
interface with policy makers and
legislators and I know there are
different tracks in Public Health
Schools and some Public Health Schools
are a little bit more research focused
some Public Health Schools are a little
bit more Hands-On in terms of getting
those skills to be able to do jobs in
public health in some schools are sort
of a mix of the two and I think all
Public Health Schools are trying to
train people to do all of the above but
I think being able to get some concrete
skills in public speaking and
presentation
analysis of data and being able to
communicate the value of the data that
you're identifying project management to
be able to say you've been given a task
and be able to see it through and be
able to actually deal with the
nitty-gritty on a lot of these things
are some very technical skills I think
some of the other things that we see in
our local Health departments for example
we
in our in Connecticut local Health
departments do a lot of the
environmental health safety so whether
this is on septic systems or sewer
systems whether you're doing food
protection safety which is another huge
thing you need scientific
training you need to have done science
classes to actually be able to
understand why does temperature
regulation of our food like if you we
oversee restaurants and want to make
sure that what they're serving is safe
and that you don't get salmonella or
something else when you go to eat in a
given restaurant well why is that in
that scientific training be able is able
to help prepare you for that so there's
really such a breath of types of jobs
that are available in public health and
getting skill sets in those various
areas are the things that I would
encourage people to think about and
think about what the end goal is even if
it's a first job right out of school and
what kinds of skills you might need to
be able to prepare yourself best and
getting some of that experiential
internship training to be able to
prepare you for that type of job at the
end
and I'm going to have Tony uh give me a
copy of our transformational plan thank
you Tony
my wonderful assistant who came from
Houston to Washington so really thank
you Tony for joining
um so we recently launched our
transformational plan and and the fall
of of this last year and I I'm so
excited about this transformation plan
um it's built on our three Cornerstone
values of equity Innovation engagement
has five areas of of reflection and one
of the areas where the first state
health agency in the nation have Global
in one Health as one of those five but
another aspect which is really exciting
in fact just this week we launched the
recruitment for the leader of that area
at our department the first time ever
that we're going to have a leader who's
going to be leading Global and one
Health together in our agency
our second area is Health Systems and
Workforce transformation and I just want
to add to what Dr jadani said and by the
way whenever she speaks I always learn
so much there's wisdom that comes it
comes from being around her
um and what I would say is the number
one thing that we have the number one
challenge we have in our field right now
is our Workforce number hands down our
Workforce is is is challenged it is it
is tired it's ragged it's been beaten up
it's been vilified it's been it's been
um attacked it's been demonized it's
been caricaturized by a a excuse my
French here bastardization of Public
Health so all the things that Dr jatani
just mentioned when you go into the
popular media when you go into a whole
host of people asking about what public
health is and or if you're going to try
to explain it to the to your neighbor
they are not going to understand
restaurant inspections or those other
things they're going to see the popular
media of what the caricature of our
field is and what that means is that
people have left our field people have
left our field and people are going to
continue to leave our field in fact the
Beaumont Foundation is saying that our
field is going to see an exodus a third
of our workers our field is going to see
in the next five years more people
leaving and third have already left
think about that so when we talk about
the skills that we need it has to be
people like you in this room and Beyond
thinking about how do we contribute to
the future of Public Health we know it's
critical but we've got to have that as
part of it the second piece is that
there are so many skill sets that are
not always taught in the theoretical
classroom of Public Health Schools or
Academia we have to have real world
experience that Dr jatani just mentioned
you have to know you have to volunteer
you have to be a part of especially in
emergencies but also in Blue Sky days
you have to be a part of that to
understand the skill sets and then the
final thing is this real a lot of the
incorporation embracing of other ways of
looking at the world whether it's debate
and dialogue how do we do that
respectfully but also forcefully and
assertively we should be willing to be
able to take our field and respond in
kind and a solidarity for our field but
the second piece of that is those skill
sets and Communications and engagement
and policy making and as I mentioned
debate and dialogue these are skill sets
that are oftentimes not taught in
schools of Public Health in the same way
that they should be in fact they're not
even taught in medical school in the way
that they should be and so we have to do
a better job with that just to expand on
it a little bit Dr Shah said that you
know these are tough times for Public
Health so there are two kinds of people
who run away from from the fire and
firefighters
you have to decide are you going to run
towards are you a firefighter is that
your calling and I think that should be
that's the ethos of our profession in
public health and Medicine
um and and there's nothing more
gratifying than to respond and the
privilege to have the skills to be able
to respond so take that as a challenge
you're coming out of programs in public
health medicine and nursing and others
and take that take up that mantle and
help redefine public health because I
can tell you on the other side there's a
lot of gratification
it's tough but you will be bad you know
your your patience will be tested uh but
but there is gratification so I we have
you know people in this room who were at
the beginning of the HIV epidemic
and there are some of the best role
models that many of us have now uh and
I'm sure they did not know how it will
end when they were in the thick of it
um in Brooklyn or you know other parts
of New York or other places
um but
um you know history will remember them
really well uh so with that I will open
up
um this you know forum for for some
questions from from the audience uh I
have plenty of questions of my own but
would love to hear something from you
there are microphones
um there so if you could raise your
hands I saw your hand first so we'll go
there first and then we'll come here
number two
and introduce yourself and then uh you
can ask your question
hi thank you so much for for your talk
um I'm Natalia mph first year student
um so I want to sleep Bitcoin a little
bit
um you talk about what you do at your
local and state level departments
um and it seems that even though the U.S
Healthcare System is such a strong and
there's so much budget and there's so
much going on uh still it was very hard
for for the pandemic um
um so how are you sharing in any way
this knowledge and preparedness
um to the global field so how is this
local knowledge translating into other
countries or other similar even states
in the US thank you
I thought thank you for that question I
thought you were going in a different
direction so maybe let me try to answer
where I thought you were about to go and
then I'll I'll try to answer your your
question specifically I thought you were
actually going into the Health Care
system and the challenge within
Healthcare and public health and so the
under investment in public health is a
real challenge that we have a real
concern so so for decades we've under
invested in public health and then we
have a a pandemic and where why are our
Data Systems not robust enough why is
the workforce you know not able to do X
Y or Z why is it that we don't have the
right systems in place why do we not
have uh Health agencies that are robust
enough to be able to respond well it's
because we've underinvested these are
these are policy choices that we've made
when 96 cents on every dollar in the US
in health is spent in health care and
we've all three of us as as Physicians
we have responded in in the medical
community we know what that means and we
have incredible amount of respect for
our medical community but we know it's
necessary but not sufficient and that's
where public health comes in so now
that's where I thought you were going
but so that was here's the here's the
the question
um so in our Global and domestic Health
work and the envisioning that we're
doing it's very much about the
bi-directionality so oftentimes in the
US we have this hubris right we're going
to take our ideas and we're going to
send them out to the world because we
have so much to teach the world when in
actuality it's bi-directional that we
have so much to teach yes but we also
have so much to learn especially in
resource constrained environments that
by the way
they feel very much like everyday USA in
many communities that are also resource
constrained so one of the tenets of our
Global work is to actually learn from
other nations and to then contribute
back with those same opportunities in
kind so we can change the landscape of
learning across the system and then Dr
judany I know you and I are both with
the association of state and territorial
Health officials and we share across
other states within the U.S so maybe you
can talk about that
yeah thanks Dr Shah I was just actually
going to say that that one of the
reasons we know each other and I learned
so much from him regularly as well is
because of the National Organization
called The Association of state and
territorial Health officials where we
meet every week sometimes more than once
a week and really have the opportunity
to learn from each other and Leverage
What one state is learning over another
one and being able to operationalize
that and I think that that camaraderie
and group is a very unique group because
there's 50 of us and then you know the
territories who participate but I
totally Echo your points on how we need
to learn so much from what's happened
globally as well I think not having you
know one Health System really in our
country has made it difficult in many
ways so many things of the coveted
response
were done in many ways better in other
countries so I think we have a lot to
learn although we have a lot to also
share with others
and if I may plug your new office
um or maybe you can sort of highlight
that because I think it's very relevant
to this question
um uh because it's I think the first
time a state health department is taking
that initiative uh for having our office
of global Health that's right we're
actually calling it Ogo uh because we
try to be a little bit you know kind of
swanky different uh the office of global
one uh which I think is really cool and
it's an opportunity for us to really be
thinking about just that and so it's it
we're actively as I mentioned we're
we're recruiting uh this week we just
launched we're so excited about this uh
the recruitment for that leader
um the the real opportunity ultimately
is to take multi-disciplinary and
interdisciplinary areas Global domestic
Health one Health right human health
animals the environment I always say
entomology as well in sex so we don't
forget mosquitoes and I was everybody
forgets mosquito I don't know why
everybody forgets mosquitoes
nobody in this room forgets mosquitoes
right okay but a lot of people do the
the intersection of all that because
that's truly what health is about and
then you throw in and and remember the
impact of climate and the changing
environment and so climate and health
and so it makes so much sense and by the
way there's an incredible resonance
drummer with with uh tribes when you
think about one health because when our
our tribal leaders they speak about one
of many of the issues that are happening
in on their lands they're very concerned
about what's happening with the
intersection of humans animals and the
environment so we're very excited about
this we think it's a path forward so
back to Dr jatani the the common is as
we are launching these things we want to
be able to share with other states and
other localities across the country and
that relationship remember we're very
close to Canada we're right next to
Canada and so we have a bi-national
relationship with
um what's happening in Vancouver or
what's happening in in the northwest
right across the border as well and this
is very much the Eighth House of the
Yale Institute for Global Health we
don't define global Health in the
context of geography we
um our core value is that
um is Health Equity that all lives are
created equal
um and populations
economic status doesn't have to dictate
their health Destiny and so therefore
when you look at it from that
perspective it's not about here and
there it's not Colonial or post-colonial
Colonial it's an orientation it's about
the shared humanity and the shared
Journey that we all have and that when
you start with that position you you
arrive at these kinds of things where
you say that all of us have to learn for
example a community healthcare worker
program is at a very essential Public
Health Innovation that for once has some
resources behind it we need to get that
right but one way we will get this right
is by learning from our you know
Partners around the world who have have
done this reasonably well not everywhere
but in more than enough places that they
are sort of valuable lessons there I'll
come to you for for the question
and as as you're going to the next
question I would just want to add when
we were vetting our transformational
plan we realized that there was
obviously resonance what was happening
in some of the larger areas but when we
went to some of our rural areas they
said you know immigrant populations and
population agricultural Farm Workers or
or other aspects or what's happening
with our folks who are going overseas or
back there is resonance there as well
with global and domestic health
thank you I'm Larry vitilano from the
child study center psychology and
Psychiatry next door at school of
medicine Professor there
um
so I wanted to ask you all what your
thoughts are about this we all are under
pressure to kind of respond to the
loudest voices
you know the loudest student in our
class or the loudest patient
um and and so we all know that if we do
that we miss out on the quiet voices
and how do you how do you think about
that and how do you
defend against you know being worried
about
the loud voices who have a lot of power
um or at least they think they do and
and and the quiet voices who feel they
don't have the power you know how do you
do that and how do you decide
where to put the resources and efforts
and you know not miss out
thank you
so I think
some people very good at advocating for
themselves and their issues
some groups are good at doing that
and sometimes they're good at doing that
for the quiet
and I think
the strength as a population is
in community organizing
and creating a Synergy of people who can
advocate for a given voice on a given
topic so that your voice does become
louder
now that doesn't answer your question on
so what do you do as somebody who's
sitting on the other side I guess I
raise that because I do think what I see
from where I am now is that it is true
that the people who are able to organize
and are able to get their message out
and are able to come together
do get their voice heard more but there
are many groups that have been
successful at doing that for often
voices that are not heard so that's a
credit to those people and those
community members who've found a way
let's take let's take gun violence as an
example you know we have groups right
here in New Haven right in Hartford that
have organized that have put themselves
together that are representing the
Grassroots whether you talk about HIV
care you know there's so many different
topics where you can get people who have
shown that they've been able to make
their voice more heard I say on on the
side of somebody who's in state
government now I think when we try to
address these topics that we recognize
because our job is really to recognize
what are the public health problems that
are really affecting our state and when
we do that to have an open mind on who
should be at the table who should be
reflecting their points and to be open
in the way that we bring those people to
to the table and I think that I see that
happening in state government but I also
would say that people who get the ear of
their state legislature there's the
legislator So for anybody who has an
issue you know talking to people who
have that seat at the table already
helps advance that point a lot of people
don't feel empowered to do that every
single one of us has the right to
contact a state representative a state
senator and vote quite frankly these are
the ways that we can exercise our agency
on these things but I do think it's on
us and what I try to do is bring all
those voices to the table anytime you're
trying to address those big problems
I would just add intentionality we have
to really be intentional in the process
and Dr Omer is an expert in this I mean
this is an area where you know he has
spent a lot of time with both
researching but also advocating and
articulating this publicly what I would
say is the one thing that will remind
ourselves is that we do hear from the
extremes on both both ends and the vast
majority of Americans the vast majority
of Americans I believe are in the middle
they're truly in the middle they're
worried about their kids going to school
they're worried about food on the table
they're worried about how their job
they're worried about the stress of
everyday life they're worried about
tomorrow
that's the vast majority and yet the
loudest voices get the the the the
airplay and that sucks the oxygen out of
the room and what the biggest challenge
for us is to be intentional so we can
also speak to both sides as well as
understand and recognize what's
happening in the middle
so although not intentional but we find
ourselves as this last conversation
Global Health conversation series event
of the Academic Year
with an all-minority panel uh and in
fact for the first time an all South
Asian panel and so I think it will be
I'll take this over to you exactly
and you won't find any of us calling
that things charity latte this it's chai
and so does everybody even understand
you might want to explain that one a
little bit more yeah well so milk tea is
chai there's no latte there's no milk
you know milk tea it's chai
and that's a hill I'm willing to die on
so coming back to that uh
um so coming back to the sort of um to
the main point that of course you know
leadership uh is often about
um sort of being the first in a room
that hasn't seen someone who looks like
you or who has the same gender or sexual
orientation or the the rural background
or first gen or the underrepresented
minority or the Immigrant background and
of course there are fewer glass ceilings
but there are ceilings made of jello
still there that they put up resistance
and so therefore there are often more
nuanced and harder to navigate
so both of you are Trailblazers from
that aspects as well
um and to put you on the spot a little
bit we get to do that in the Academia
that's why God created tenure
um
for you but not for us
so so so so maybe you can start Dr Shah
and then Dr titani will end up with your
thoughts on this uh something that that
you know lessons from being Trail
brazers
you know I I think the lesson that I
take away is that yes we're we're South
Asian from a background standpoint but
it's more than that that is where we
come from that's maybe our maybe our
value helped uh instill values it's
where our families our our ways of
learning you know how our parents raised
us our culture our food so much
incredible Rich heritage
But ultimately when you're in the work
world and when you're in the
professional world it's about competence
and we want to make sure that the people
are good at what they do and that is the
ultimate number one thing
but we also recognize to the earlier
question about intentionality when we
are also looking to
to our Workforce or to the next
generation of leaders like all of you we
have to be intentional in making sure
that we're also Broad in our perspective
and approach so we also look like and
and start to mirror the very communities
that we serve and that has not always
happened in this country and that's why
it's got to be an equity-based approach
and truly that is where leaders like us
can bring that trail blazing if that's
what it's called I really believe it's
really the way we should operate and do
our work
so I think many people saw many South
Asians at the Forefront of the covid
pandemic on TV in your hospitals
everywhere and
um you know the I see us as standing on
the shoulders of giants our parents and
others who came before us that helped
get us here and I think in terms of
being you know the first or in these
roles these new roles that are more
public facing I view that as an honor
privilege and obligation to be competent
and to do the job well and to showcase
for others that if I can do it you can
do it that all of you who are in the
room you know you are students now you
were inspired by covid you were here
because you wanted to be a firefighter
because you wanted to be at the
Forefront of addressing these concerns
and so I see that as our Challenge and
uh goal is to inspire and show others
that you too can do it that you too can
join this fight as we try to advocate
for what's most important in health in
our society and in our country
thank you uh really appreciate it and
um it's a privilege to have you as
guests
um for for this conversation series and
thank you for for coming as you know
that this is a new era for public health
you you all have to do you know
especially the students and early stage
faculty have to do better uh than than
us uh you know than the current cohort
uh because there's no other choice
because the next generation of
challenges at the State uh local and
Global levels are existential so the
impact of global climate change uh the
fact that we have had a shrinkage in
life expectancy in the richest country
in the world the fact that this city is
map of covet mortality looked like we're
brown and black people lived
um that should be an unacceptable but we
have the privilege of having the tools
um and being at institutions and having
access to the knowledge and
understanding uh to to to gear up for
that uh that that struggle that fight if
you will uh so no pressure thank you
foreign
[Music]